've been talking with you for a years at this
point about the complete, the
utterly destructive nature of Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu, his presence
in Israeli politics.
This is a guy who I've been saying for years
just has to go, and there are many impediments
to peace in the Israeli Palestinian conflict.
As many of you in the audience know, I've
not been shy about naming all of them, but
Benjamin Netanyahu is one of them.
This is not a guy who wants peace in the sense
that it doesn't benefit him politically to
have serious discussions that might lead to
a peace agreement.
And I know there are plenty of other parties
who also don't benefit from peace, but we're
talking about Benjamin Netanyahu today.
Nothing.
Yahoo is heavily aligned with the most extreme
religious elements of the Israeli political
sphere.
Almost everything that he does is counterproductive
to the goal of a path to a long lasting and
permanent peace agreement.
And he benefits from the status quo not being
that and being one of threats and being on
the verge of something all the time.
So we heard yesterday, Benjamin Netanyahu
is going to make a big announcement.
It is just going to be a huge, huge, huge
announcement that he is going to be making
by the way, a week before the election in
Israel.
How exciting.
And of course I assumed it would be some horrible
thing or some brazen distraction of some kind.
And it was Benjamin Netanyahu.
His big announcement is that if Israelis reelect
him, he will take more land.
He will annex pieces of the West Bank, much
to pleasure of people associated with Donald
Trump's administration here in the United
States.
And in this particular case, Benjamin Netanyahu
is talking about the Jordan Valley and the
Northern Dead Sea.
The Trump administration of course was asked
officially, do you support this idea?
They simply said, our policy has not changed,
but intimating that pretty clearly.
They're not going to get in the way of Benjamin
Netanyahu doing this if he is indeed reelected.
So this is a very brazen tactic from Netanyahu.
We've seen this before.
He's worried about losing.
He's not polling well.
It would be great for him to lose by the way.
So he has done what he always does.
He has concocted this dramatic announcement
riddled with red meat of different kinds,
appealing to fears about terrorism and so
on and so forth, which are not unfounded fears,
but he appeals to them in an irrational way,
which is not actually a dramatic in the sense
that he wanted it to be.
It's just horrible.
It's a horrible idea.
He's done this before prior elections.
It unfortunately does have an effect in the
same way that here in the United States sometimes
you'll see republicans before an election
pull national security games.
All, we've got a new recording from Osama
bin Ladin.
Remember that very similar dynamic being employed
in Israeli politics.
So let's hope that he's voted out.
Um, then maybe if Donald Trump is also voted
out, we can make some progress towards in
Israeli Palestinian peace agreement, the parameters
of which, as I see them, I've laid out many
times on the program.
Uh, but again, it is also more than just removing
Benjamin Netanyahu.
As I've talked about before, there is much
more to it, including having Donald Trump,
a Benjamin Netanyahu sycophant in the White
House in the United States.
Now, one impediment that I've talked about
many times is not the annexation specifically,
but settlements.
And the way that this always works with these
annexations is Israel says, you know, we need
to create a defensive buffer between Palestinian
territory and Israeli territory.
So we need this little stretch of land here.
It's just a small stretch of land.
They take it and then settlers go into those
buffer zones, which moves the perimeter at
which yet another buffer zone is supposedly
needed, which justifies or at least creates
the pretext for Benjamin Netanyahu to again
say, listen, we've got to have a protective
buffer in now this new line that has been
drawn, the settlements have to stop there.
One of the biggest impediments to peace, big
picture, and I know you all know this, a ton
of stuff has, has to change.
It is not just Israeli policy that has to
change on the Palestinian side.
There is a long list of policies and people
and practices and status quo that will never
lead to peace.
And I've been clear about it, I've not been
shy about saying that, but this game that
Benjamin Netanyahu is playing is completely
backwards.
So let's hope that the promise of this dramatic,
uh, annexation of more West Bank land ends
up being nothing more than a late, a naked
election, a electioneering attempt, and that
Benjamin Netanyahu will lose and thus not
even have the chance to make good on this
promise because it will only lead to more
of the same and more of what we've been seeing
under this guys, numerous administrations
over the years.